-I -- Guys, I have a book out --
coming out called
"Nana Loves You More."
I'm very excited about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is -- This one --
This one's $17.99.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, $1,799.
-Wow, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Look at what you get here.
-That's a lot of pages.
-Look at the thickness.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And in there, but this --
this is the --
this is the new --
in this series,
you have "Dada," you have
"Mama," "Baby," "Nana."
But I'm gonna get into it.
I want to have a theme week --
a nana theme week.
Next week is all --
We're gonna celebrate grandmas
around the country,
and we love grandmas,
and so check our socials.
We're gonna -- We might need
your grandmas to participate
and do something fun
for our show.
So check the @FallonTonight
or @JimmyFallon.
It's gonna be fun.